- I heard that you have a
collector's item at home.
Okay, Super Bowl winning quarterback
Patrick Mahomes.
(Henry gasps)
Yes, signed a jersey for you.
- He did.
- Yeah.
I was at that Super Bowl.
- I just talked about
him on Rich Eisen's show.
- Yeah.
- And so then I said to
him, I said, you know,
if he ever comes to my house.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He would get like a
chicken stuffed with ricotta
and spinach with a reduction sauce.
- (gasps) What?
- And then he, Rich Eisen,
played that for Mr. Mahomes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was invited to a
game here at SoFi Stadium,
I walked down on the field,
he comes running up to me,
this is a very big person.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Henry] This is about
6 or 7 people in one.
(audience laughs)
And here's the thing,
you know when you hug somebody,
and your finger, you push in
and there's a little give?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No give.
- Yeah, so like my body?
- It's like a can.
- Yeah.
- It's like a can of soup.
- [Kelly] It's hard.
- Yeah, hard.
And he said, "I've got
a surprise for you."
And he gave me his jersey.
- That's so cool.
- Okay.
(audience clapping)
- I love that.
(Henry stutters)
Did you have the dinner?
- Huh?
- Did you invite him to dinner?
- Okay, so this is the thing,
So, now he runs off...
Now he's gonna play a big game,
hitting and running and throwing
and hurting and you know.
- All the things.
- Yeah.
- And just before, as he runs off,
He turns around he goes,
"I'm gonna take you up on that dinner."
- [audience member] Woo.
- And he's gone.
(audience clapping)
- When?
- Okay well.
- I'd like to know when.
- He had to win a Super Bowl first.
- He did.
- Yeah.